Her low freak bitches,
like going to a Korean restaurant.
My one of my buddies is Roy Choi.
I haven't talked to him forever,
but we used to live next to,
he did a,
he's the chef and he out him on the
podcast and uh,
well he took us,
he did a,
he does the Kogi Taco truck.
He's got him on the podcast.
Yeah,
no,
you did 100% wrong.
Nope.
He,
he came in with Eddie Wong.
But Roy Choi is a very famous chef.
One of the most famous famous chefs in
La Right now.
Not Episode was this type in Roikoi uh,
Joe Rogan.
I promise you.
As I watched it and I was like,
so he was with Eddie?
Yeah.
No,
nope.
He was,
no,
I'm a hundred percent certain.
Well,
I fight fight that.
Google's right.
Nope.
I am 100% certain.
Eddie Wong came in one time with the guy
that was in that movie.
The interview.
I'm,
I'm going to go to the match on this
one.
I'm looking at it right now.
I just spoke with it.
And you're wrong.
So Bert Kreischer is going deep and he's
taking chances.
Predictions.
He's challenging young Jamie on the air
boy choice.
I think we got a little too high before
the show.
Rogue and honest with you.
We got a little ridiculous Roy Choi.
I did.
I misspell it.
Roy Choi,
Joe Rogan experience with Brian Stann.
Hmm.
What?
No,
that's definitely not true.
It says,
it says Roy Choi.
I promise you.
Well,
Brian,
Stan was definitely by himself.
Can Right?
Can someone please just tweet the
fucking answer to me cause I promised
you I saw it and I would make these
people do the work when you're not doing
this.
I'm not too far.
I'm too fucked up to do the okay.
But I promise you it was on in here one
time.
I know he's wrong,
but I'm like God damn he right.
Roy Choi fucking Jamie.
The Roy Choi created the TACO truck
crane.
Uh,
he's good friends with Anthony Bourdain
and uh,
sorry,
maybe you're spelling it wrong.
Racist.
Whoa.
Dare you.
How dare you cast upon him a moniker
that cannot be shaken.
So anyway,
damn,
I don't even know where if I was going
with his point wines.
It's getting hot in here.
All sorts of different types of alcohol.
We're probably out of wine,
wine,
young Jamie,
Jamie's gonna find out.
But I don't know where my point with
this going.
Oh he took,
he took me and my wife to uh,
he took me and my wife to um,
uh,
to Korea town to go eat Korean barbecue
cause he wanted to teach us real Korean
barbecue,
like what they eat,
not the kind that we believe it is.
Right.
And it was interesting.
We went in there and no one's spoken,
no one,
there were not only were there any white
people,
no one spoke English at work there.
And so we actually were complete and
total tourists in our own town and just
sat and watched him order and,
and he just was like,
don't worry,
I'll,
and it was really fascinating
experience.
Would I want that place to ever go away?
Never in a million fucking years.
I want those places to last as long as
son of a bitch.
Champagne motherfucker brought out
champagne.
Damn.
Isn't it?
Is this cause you're wrong and Ma Fucka
a birthday.
Uh,
but uh,
but like I believe in that.
I know,
but I I,
but then again,
we're on the same liberal side of the
fence because I am a,
I've,
maybe I'm a libertarian or whatever.
I am.
I'm a liberal.
I'm a conservative liberal or
conservative.
Liberal.
Yeah.
What do you liberal about?
Like gay rights,
gay rights,
all rights,
all human rights,
all female gay rights,
transgender or you name it.
I don't want you to feel like shit.
If I can help that,
that's my job as a comic.
My only goal is to make people laugh.
Why would I ever want anyone to feel bad
about their day?
That's not my emo.
Beautiful.
And what do you conservative about?
Um,
like blacks?
No,
no,
the right to tell that joke to you.
Yes.
Good.
That's what I'm conservative about.
Is that conservative anymore?
Yes,
it is because it's still conservative.
Is Conservative value to be able to
express yourself in a way that it'd be
offensive.
Did you see that the recent ruling,
young Jamie pulled this up?
It's kind of interesting.
The court ruled against this idea that
uh,
there should be laws against,
what can I calm down?
Brighton.
I'm about to release the crackin.
He's going to open this cork and Brian
is terrified.
Like he's never been to the gun range.
I had one of those hit me in the eye
before.
Oh,
there you are partying with the wrong
people.
Sign it into that wine and make a fine
rosie Zinfandel or some shit.
A wine cooler.
A bit.
That's like a watermelon lime cooler.
Barlow,
James Bartles and jaymes strawberry,
right?
Strawberry.
I'm not drinking.
Double it up.
Mother drink during the day.
It doesn't take one of the gin.
Hey,
whoa,
listen.
Okay.
What I'm going to hammered right now
that we're all hammered.
We're all stone too.
You just said you went to take it on the
Chin after giving a story about a man
massaging somebody that I'm really like
down in the Internet,
not backing me up with his roy toy thing
and I started right.
It looks like,
but I'm pretty sure he's right.
He's not right,
right.
Almost all the time.
Is that racist?
Is Not Racist.
It's just a gong.
Can we get away with a Gong for anybody
gets mad?
David Cho or that you're thinking of?
No,
it's Roy Choi.
I want to fucking call him.
God has no nothing.
It's a void choice.
Sorry,
sorry.
Sorry.
I'm looking at all the Eddie Wong
episodes when he was in here.
He wasn't in here sweetie.
It's okay.
Jamie.
I'm sorry.
I mean this is the only place I've
worked here.
I was in this building and I pretty much
remember every single one.
It would have to be super old school,
like to the point where I don't remember
it anymore.
Last time you were on the show,
we drove home together or the time
before and you talked about your friend.
So it must have been within the last
three months then I would,
I only know this cause he's done the,
he's been done for Dane tumor,
something going on here.
He's telling me here,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
I hydrated.
He,
I've,
he's done bourdain show and he's done
your podcast and he'd do neither for me.
So I remember going like,
like a per day and I get it.
Why wouldn't you go on with Bourdain?
One of the greatest people on television
for chefs,
but I was like podcast wise,
like I was like,
I was like,
and I get why you do joe,
but like throw me a bone Roy.
Like we were,
he's a good guy.
He's a great guy.
But his,
uh,
um,
no,
I don't want to get removed from the
podcast.
Eddie Wong and Shane Smith.
I guarantee let's,
maybe you hold on.
No,
no,
no.
Go to the video.
Go to the video and see if there's
another Asian guy.
Was there another Asian guy in here with
them?
Their lunch time there was,
there was a,
it was the dude from a party.
He was from that show.
The show off.
Was it?
What was it?
Off the boat.
Fresh off the boat I was spending,
now I know what I'm doing tonight.
It's no big deal,
dude.
He can be wrong.
I think you're wrong.
Attach your whole life to this.
It's just too hard to win and every
phone life to let some certain losses,
they're going to come your way and
you've got to regroup and you've got to
pick up the paces,
paces,
pick up the pieces and move on with your
life for Christ or bigger fan of your
podcast and you are of your podcasts.
I watch all of them.
Sharon,
how could you ever say that?
That Joe Rogan's,
he's not saying anything either.
So David Choe found it.
I don't even think anybody named Roy has
been on the podcast.
Came on with David Show.
Yup,
he did.
He's right here.
David was been on a few times,
maybe came to one of the ice house
chronicles.
Was it a nice house?
Chronical?
Nope.
I'm going through,
this was David's show.
I did David show once.
That's it.
It was five 92 with David.
She was the one episode I wasn't here.
Oh Shit.
Could have been the one episode,
but Jamie was on five 63 that can't be
that dumb,
dumb,
dumb.
What gave it shows podcasts that when
Joe Rogan was on that podcast could have
been.
I think that's,
it makes more sense.
Number five 92 I have a,
this is horrible podcasting and no,
it's not.
I have a hard time believing when we've
actually done 750 podcasts.
I was all five 90 27697006969 bro.
You've done 769 podcasts.
Indeed preposterous.
It's great man.
I like what you did and I don't know,
I think I may have told you this one
thing fucked up.
I'm,
I'm very,
uh,
I'm envious in a sense of what you've
done and only,
I only had that I could not do it.
Begin it now.
What you did is you kind of took,
you kind of took the renaissance to
yourself and you allowed people that
think differently than you to come to
you and talk to you and you got to kind
of soak in the information like a sponge
as a stand up man.
That is like,
that's the fucking,
that's what we all should be doing.
Instead of just sitting around and
going,
what does this guy think about
airplanes?
What is it?
You know what I mean?
You really kind of broadened the
spectrum of what you want to talk about
on stage.
And I remember hearing Chris rock say
that he got invited to Cornell Wallace's
house for Sunday dinners and right
before he did his most monumental hour
and he was like,
you know,
it was really cool.
I didn't say anything.
I just would sit and listen to all these
great Glenn Wallace or West Cornell
West,
my dad,
Hey Bert Roy troy was an episode of
getting Doug with high with Horatio's
sands.
Uh,
Kuroshio and me have often been
confused.
There's no way I might think of Doug
with the high.
Yes,
yes you are.
Oh,
are you serious?
Yo,
it happens.
Let it go.
Just embrace the loss.
Take it on the Chin and move forward.
Soldier on,
sir.
It's no big deal.
Burt wanted minute.
Look at them.
Very competitive,
very competitive.
Getting Doug with high.
You know what?
You hit.
Hit debunked this.
Are you ready for me to debunk a
scientist?
Hoping you can do it.
Here we go.
Mike.
Drop moment.
Dear scientist who spent her whole life
figuring this out,
I just shut you down so I built a time
trouble.
Me and Brian are time travel consists of
a bottle of champagne,
a lighter and a joint.
Right?
I'm just saying simple,
simpler time machine.
Yeah.
Stops or join in on this.
Can I handle this one on my own?
So I'm so let's play.
I'm just saying simple mechanics.
Let's pretend that that's the time
machine,
right?
We got it.
All right.
We invent a time machine.
God,
Oh my God,
we right now we can travel back to that
moment three days ago.
We can try to travel back to this moment
or three days to know.
I can say to Brian,
hey,
our time machine really just consists of
a bottle of champagne,
a joint and lighter.
Go to f,
let's fucking send you back.
You know the three things.
Bill one then come back to me.
Now your idea,
she gets together with my chipolte lay
person.
They have sex and have a baby.
That makes no sense you guys.
There's no time machine never going to
be built because Donald Trump is
president and dogs living together.
We're a simulation program.
Time machine doesn't matter.
Burt's ideas back to the future.
Three basically.
Is that what it is,
Jamie?
Jamie shutting your shit down.
Stuck what they do to your,
you're interrupting your Kettle Bell
Workout on a stop shutting down.
Oh fuck.
Okay.